dan tell me you're not kidding dude no
way - congrats bro what I flew from
Island to Cape Town to plan something
but personally need a haircut shower and
a shave cool before we dive shed into
the deep end he has a pretty interesting
story after a long business trip to
Kenya sitting having a drink with some
friends that it makes a combined kata
when I saw a beautiful brunette with a
smile that immediately got my mind
racing with a million damn pickup lines
I was so drawn to this person for one
quick glance none of the bigger plans
would suffice so I pulled away just
aside and said please get that girl over
there a friend two tequilas
they arrived and she looked at me with
excitement started walking over and to
my horror scream Dan and with an inkling
of a teenage smile I remembered Gabi
my best friend from school Nick's sister
she had always been out of bounds she
stood in front of me with a big curious
eyes and said it's been ages hey yo I
haven't even seen Nick in about two
years
hope I felt some hope with a newly
gained confidence I said we should get a
drink tomorrow night's at hustle
machines
she accepted and boomed like an
explosion I felt my heart beats in a way
it hadn't before my smile extended an
inch further out my cheek quite frankly
I hadn't been this excited since
quitting film school the next morning I
got a text from Nick that radio Yuri
drinks tonight at awesome machines this
couldn't be what am I gonna do I thought
the bro card the card II had pulled
earlier that year the card that made one
pass on almost anything
as I approached him that night he said
Ruth gabs told me about you and her
going on a date I couldn't be more
stoked just don't [ __ ] it up
all of that stress for nothing and I've
got to keep my bro card since that night
it's been two and a half years endless
laughs a son Joe boy awkward dance moves
late nights when's losses a relocation
to New York all the most humble
intelligent gorgeous women and I've
gotten to a point in my life where all I
want to do is be with this one person
essentially I want to ask ABS to marry
me in three days time this is the
biggest commitment I could possibly make
and it's it's quite honestly and scaring
the [ __ ] out of me
therefore I wrote myself the list an
unscrupulous list of to Do's within the
next three days before I asked for God's
hand in marriage step one on the do not
screw up list is to film the entire
process in a respectful and non-invasive
manner what does that mean this
engagement or proposal is something
that's super personal something that's a
very special moment for both myself and
for gabs and I don't in any way want to
exploit that I do however want to
capture it as I'm a filmmaker so I'm
going to make a film out of it but it
needs to be real I really want to
capture the essence of what it is like
to go through this process and to do
this successfully you'll need the
following topics black gaffer tape
scissors fabric paint random fabric
decorations fabric glue super glue
action camera hipster moon bags and
window shade
okay I introduced you the brew bag thank
goodness for hipsters because this is
actually now an acceptable accessory
I am busy filming you and then add to
all these self-proclaimed film critics I
see you I'll be using this camera where
I can wear it's non-invasive just
because the quality of the blue bag just
isn't the same so in between this yes
there will be quite a lot of footage
that doesn't have the netting over it
that is because it was shot on my g h5
good morning my fine sir how you brew I
want to tell you something special
sweet bread number two on the list ask
her brother and father for their
blessing and then I'm also going to
combine it with number four which is
fast good friends and Tom up here well
that's if point number two goes okay
[Music]
describe it out in three words mailer
mysterious and serious Nick completely
ruin the surprise when IRA is Brian like
you saved me a message and literally
saying that I saw a special Tommy flew
down to Cape Town I breathe obviously
the main purpose of tinnitus to actually
asked Nick's dad what do you think he's
gonna say haha
Bri that he's gonna be Hugh yeah what
should I do for dinner tonight okay
that's easy
steak chocolate coated peanuts red wine
I burned the steak
therefore I had a book a table at a
local steak
[Music]
makes me what yeah and I'll just be out
of that one today okay wait I even begin
yeah that was the most cringe-worthy
awkward position I've ever been in in my
entire life basically making his dad
decided they were gonna screw with me
and they kind of really told his dad
about the Gabby situation prior to us
meeting I get it but not funny
[Applause]
thank you
yeah I'm thinking of proposing to
Gabrielle I'm gonna propose to gobs on
Tuesday I've decided I'm gonna propose
to go yeah yeah
[Music]
now that I can move on I need to get a
ring in less than 48 hours incoming
right now yeah I can literally okay cool
where are you based
[Music]
this is all of a sudden become really
real I've got a rage for those
interested this is a platinum band these
mini diamonds all around the big one on
top step number five is to involve Joe
boy firstly I'm gonna have to steal his
favorite pink jacket
don't tell them and then I'm gonna take
the ring I'm gonna put it on the stove
little lay the pouch and they take this
blue little material part apply this
near the pouch inside it and then attach
it to this pink jersey you got this boy
[Music]
in exactly 45 minutes Gabi's going to be
walking through that door we're on the
sixth and final objective on the do not
screw up list which I happen to lose
along my missions today because it's
been really [ __ ] frantic and I'm
freaking out but this section is called
surprising Gabi which is the part that
I'm actually gonna get down onto my knee
and propose so it's gonna go something
like this I'm gonna put one camera up
there another one hiding in this little
bush and my friend Luke is gonna keep
Joe locked in this room until grabs on
myself have been sitting down there for
one minute with ten minutes to spare
it's time to cue that I've sung playlist
let's do this
what do you think about my
[Music]
such a baby
oh boy
[Music]
open the path
- try not to cry
Gabrielle Esther Hazen the love of my
life I [ __ ] love you so much gasps
will you marry me it seems a left my
outside your door
it seems a left my heart
outside
[Music]
this is where the old me inside it's
alright I swear that I feel I'm fine and
this is where the hole
it's alright I swear that I feel I'm
fine
oh you so many
but I will fill my life why are we lying
down like this because it looks cool you
like it yeah I think you vendor ID to
sign out this movie cuz you always do
that no big food ah thanks for watching
Bru
ah thanks for watching food don't forget
to Like and subscribe and comment and
all the things and you want to marry me
if I sound like that when I guess that
pretty much covers it also you can
follow me on Instagram to keep up with
me pretty much daily there as well as
Twitter and then don't forget your
awesome brew and thank you for following
us on this journey
see you on Wednesday
this is where the old mints
it's alright I swear that I feel I'm
fine and this is with a hold on me
it's alright I spray that I feel I'm
fine
wanna tell you so many
but I waited for the office to fill my
life when I was good to see about